[Music]
listen to this corporate music
i feel like i'm about to go into a
finance meeting or praise jesus
[Music]
still not sure hello everybody my name
is markiplier and welcome to the last
stop on the bus of simulator games lawn
mowing simulator or it's the next stop
on a new horizon of adventures for me in
the world of simulation i saw this game
and i had to play it i bought it
immediately i had to i must you must
understand
i had no
all right tutorials i really didn't want
to but let's do it
in this mode you create your own lawn
mowing company and build up its
reputation as you expand your company
you can hire employees purchase more
mowers and unlock new contracts but
first your company needs setting up with
a name logo and uniform okay
t
t
t t
to d
to t
d
okay company logo grass
we cut grass you got grass in your ass
we'll cut that grass here at d
we could grace player name my name is d
owner of the
avatar
yes
the
hat
d
logo can i spin him
can i spin him no
no look
back only
that was tough
i hate i hate
customization i hate it i hate it wow a
stiga mulcher type deck this vehicle is
equipped with a mulcher type deck that
means you can cut with it the grass
clippings are cut so small no visible
blades are left no piles of grass
clippings will be left unless you
overload the engine which will mean the
deck doesn't have the power to cut the
grass blades side discharge it blasts it
out the side i know how it works oh look
at that chair oh
test drive no i don't need to test drive
it i buy straight up okay but this oh
oh this has a higher top speed i'd
really be going
[Music]
more fuel capacity
ooh
damn look at that thing's top speed oh
that's got a beefy engine too huh
the choices the choices well if i'm
gonna be riding my ass in something uh
it's like a go-kart though
[Music]
wait am i not
actually buying these what is the point
of this if i can't actually uh all right
fine go back i guess am i supposed to
test right let's try the zippy one i
know it's probably a pain in the ass
because i gotta go collect my clippings
again here you can familiar whatever
test drive area whoa
all right
get on vehicle once you're on the
vehicle you will need to get started
under the grass these vehicles slightly
different to get going for all the steps
start at the bottom
when the vehicle started to take a
moment to get you through and then drive
over the grass oh inverted controls
that's interesting choice uh gonna
change that immediately anyone that uses
inverted
look is
terrible what do you mean invert it's
already inverted that's
better yeah that's better that's more
that making more sense
no that don't make more sense no yes
this no wait hang on am i am i the
criminal
no
no it's still doing it
i'm not the criminal you're the criminal
there we go
if i want to look down i look that's
more like it okay let's start this bad
boy i'm holding z how long is it oh
i to t right
right t
ooh
e
c
oh cut height real low
let's screw wow it's zippy
[Music]
i'm going 10 miles an hour and i've
never had more fun all right here comes
d
everyone watch out
oh
once on the grass you'll need to get
your deck ready by setting it to the cut
height and then engaging the cutting
blades you should only ever turn on your
blades when on grass otherwise you will
damage them and they'll affect their
ability to cut
okay
z
cut height
set your cut height within range of five
centimeters
five
perfect
oh yeah
oh she's a wild one
oh she's a wily one wow
we've uh
we've uh we've oh
god why would you do that to me
why
oh god oh god
there we go there we go
okay here we go here we go here we go
man keyboard is not what this was meant
for
[Music]
this brings me back to my days of
cutting my mom's lawn
ah
what a delight
[Music]
oh no
oh no guys oh no i'm enjoying it oh no
guys
hold on
wait
oh no
i'm enjoying myself
oh no
oh no
oh man i can see myself going out and
buying one of those like steering wheel
things so i could really enjoy
some proper cut oh
look at that oh
oh
my god it is i oh it is oh
it is i don't know if that's a strip i'm
missing why does it look like that
by holding ctrl you can engage pro view
which highlights grass that have not
been cut to the record okay
ah
what was it control oh
so what i always did is i i tried to
align the wheels as best i could when i
how many out there of you have lawn
mowed before
how many i mean i know that i'm not it's
not the best to go in a circus path and
it's best to just like
do the straight lines cause those look
better
but also shut up and go away this is my
lawn mowing and you won't intrude with
your thoughts and your opinions about
how my lawn should be mowed and if you
ever come in here again with a goddamn
opinion i will shove it so far off your
ass you'll never see the light again
again weather was nice today
it was kind of chilly out and i liked
that
i like the crisp air
[Music]
what did that say
there's some kind of like
i you know what i'm gonna ruin
everyone's day
i'm overloading the engine guys guys i'm
overloading it wouldn't want to kick
this bad boy into high gear
he
ah there's no high gear
okay whatever why is it why is it like
this oh
i'm in this view mode right look at this
stud look at d go
god imagine you just hired this dude
with a one letter company name to mow
your lawn and he just starts going at it
you know roomba style that's really what
i'm about how do i wave roomba style
you know roomba's gotta know something
good you know rumors gotta understand
something that we don't as mere mortals
do
bomb
bomb
whom
well i'm almost done guys man i wish
power washing simulator you only had to
do like
20
and then jobs done who who hires someone
to cut 20 of their lawn
twenty percent good enough hey frank
it's fine just stop right there i like
seeing half of it grow
i like seeing it grow wild but only in
certain spots what if i increase my cut
eye no cutting at the wrong height
pro view wait
my pro senses are tingling
oh
fascinating
i now know what i need to do
i now know
[Music]
i wonder if there's like uh can i break
this is there like a mod for this that i
can just really increase the speed and
like triple the width of my lawnmower
can i get one of those industrial
engines from like farming simulator of
which i bet this is all the assets from
farming simulator oh yay i did it in a
real contract however you will be
expected to cut all the grass when i
contracted
great
i guess i'm done
let me disengage the cutting blades
nice and let me drive it back onto the
trailer of which i have no truck
i'm the best purchase a vehicle great
well i tried that one
and i did not feel like i was in the lap
of luxury however it was nice and speedy
which i did appreciate but i really wish
i could afford these i'm gonna go with
the yellow one
because i imagine
that i need to collect
mulch it
nice and slow but powerful i like this
one it looks great wait how much is this
one cheap
yeah
i'll go i'll spend the money i'll spend
the money i ain't going where with
anywhere with this one i'll spend the
money once you select a contract you can
see information about his value and
requirements if you wish to accept the
contract you first need to assign an
employee and vehicle i am the employee
i am the vehicle
i confirmed this
[Music]
okay
i did it ground check you didn't tell me
about anything like that
got the old nook cottage
i'd the old nook
confirm
all right oh i missed the thing about
the ground check i was supposed to look
at that and i didn't are you sure you
want to exit ground check remaining
object will be automatically oh yeah i
need to go check the ground to make sure
that i don't run over anything important
you have to sprint yeah you oh look at
this
look at this
look at this nonsense
look at these useless careless children
leaving toys what is this
what is this garbage in my yard
was that poop
did someone leave bloop in my yard
how dare they i'm gonna find the animal
to shed this out and i'm gonna shove it
so far up it's so nice
time to mow that lawn
i'm ready all right throttle up baby oh
3 000 rpm
oh yeah
and let's engage the cutting blades you
lower the dick
z
hell yeah
now this is how you do it this is how
you do it everybody this is what you do
you see what i'm doing
this is exactly what you do this is
goddamn authentic ain't it
oh i destroyed a flower well [ __ ]
accidents happen i'm really trying guys
i'm really trying
this is uh
not easy with a keyboard but i'm doing
all right
so far so good
i'm actually gonna try you know as much
as it might you might guys might be like
oh he's just gonna dick around and this
was like no
no no no no no
just tracing the outsides real quick
then i'm going to pick my lines here we
go
yeah
this is how we do
and then and then and then
and then hold on hold on hold on
hold on
hold on hold on wait wait for it
i loved whoa
oh
there we go and pick my line and pick my
line and let's really look at it let's
really look at it
yeah
is it gonna make the alternating
striation patterns if this doesn't make
the alternating striation patterns i
walk away
i'm not gonna walk away it was an empty
threat all right let's get to work
it really is just like i'm back at my
mom's house mowing the goddamn lawn
and this thing turns on a dime
oh motor overloaded what do you mean
what are we cutting too much grass i'm
cutting the exact amount of grass that i
had
what do you what do you mean what were
you referring to that the motor was
overloaded
is this like a challenge
something horrible that's going on in
the game that i need to actually pay
attention to because i won't
i refuse to grasp my speed
thick in those parts i guess
[Music]
[Music]
this one is kind of nice
just the way that it mulches as you cut
so you don't have to worry so much about
collecting it bagging it
taking it over to the compost heap
you know it's a kind of
comfy ride too you know the suspension
system on this bad boy is uh built by
germans
germans if there's one thing the germans
know it's
it's beer and suspensions
sauerkraut
and precision engineering those germans
they know god my life is boring
i had ambitions once
hopes
yearnings as some i call them
i was destined for big things and then
uh
well you know
you know make it to minor leagues and
you just don't uh
yeah
pump out a few kids and uh next thing
you know your
figure's gone to [ __ ] and uh
you uh
we're gonna nine to five over at the
local repair shop and um all those uh
glory days are uh long gone and in the
past and i'll never relive those ever
again
i just only have uh
lawn mowing to look forward to sometimes
i still play
still play i mean uh me and the
neighbors we i don't really like them
but we got this um yeah this kickball
league it's almost like i i made it
to the big leagues
and some with thinking that we're good
enough that we might be able to go to
win this just win the local
kickball tournament i have a trophy and
a gift card
applebee's that'd be cool if we won that
i collect stamps i like stamps
they're timeless you know timeless just
like my memories
the memories of the past you know and
how
i look back on all of them and i can
remember fondly when i had joy in my
life
not that i don't have joy now why would
i not have joy now
[Laughter]
[Music]
never look out at your neighbor mowing
their lawn they're just sobbing openly
as they cut their grass
that's what's going through my mind
right now i'm really channeling
channeling my neighbor i hate to say it
but i am starting to get into it
like i said before that i was liking it
and it really does kind of have the
therapy
of
oh now here's the kicker strategy does
anyone else do that anyone else do that
move whoa hey oh oh oh oh oh oh the
ground anyone else do that move you kind
of go out and then in and then you cover
the circle you can't trace that circle
because you can't turn that sharp your
wheels will dig into the ground and i
guess i cut up a few
a few bricks at the same time but hey
that ain't no big deal ain't no big deal
at all
nice
nice grout i damaged the ground
yeah you're right i probably did
well fine incurred you make it seem like
it's a crime
like when you say fine that really does
seem like you're gonna have someone
arrest me if i don't pay it as far as
i'm concerned i'm being paid here for my
hard work my tears are watering the
ground
aren't you happy
shouldn't someone at least be happy here
oops sorry about that
didn't mean to do it i've always wanted
to do that
whenever whenever i was like mowing the
lawn you know i would i would i would
never i would never i would never do
such a thing i would never
well you know the temptation was always
there just to go straight through the
the flower bed boy the temptation was
there
damaged the ground damaged my ass
damaged my ass try you can't it's
impossible my ass is invincible i'll go
through this convenient path through the
flowers
man they were nice to leave that for me
i'm almost done
i can almost smell the peanut butter and
jelly sandwich that my mom made for me
that's a lie my mom's korean she
wouldn't make that i can smell the
chop-che and bulgogi that my mom made me
i can smell the bean sprouts soup right
now um
actually turnip soup not that she didn't
make bean sprout soup turnip soup
that was quite good
i'm not damaging the ground
yay i did it
ah let's turn off these cutting blades
oh raise the motor code or whatever it
is
and let's get out of here
job well done
job greatly ignore the track marks
job well done
job well done i did it
look at that
if you want to get off the vehicle for
any reason press an old q
if you want to rage quit and tear up
some flowers with your bare hands rescue
hey
look at that
that's a lot of money i did it
it only cost me 12 pounds
12 uk pounds to be able to mow over
those flowers that's great job well done
everybody
i really did it to be perfectly honest
this is not as satisfying as power wash
simulator but it is satisfying in its
own way you know i i can't deny
there's something satisfying about
mowing the lawn however
it doesn't have the same visceral
interest as like power washing does the
cleanliness of it anyway i think i'm
good i don't need to go again if you
want to check out lawn mowing simulator
there's a link in the description you
can check out it for yourself and thank
you everybody so much for watching check
out the other simulator games that i've
played in the link in the description
below i gotta get a new playlist for
just simulator games because i've played
a lot of them so thank you and as always
i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
so